[Music]
water elastic and plastic deformations
well deformation means the change in
shape and/or size of the body and the
force which deforms an object is called
d-forming force elastic deformation is
the case of deformation where the body
regains its original shape as soon as
the d-forming force is removed but what
really happens in a state of deformation
there is a restoring force generated
inside the body resisting the
deformation yes a restoring force when
the body is in equilibrium this
restoring force is equal in magnitude to
the d-forming force and acts in opposite
direction and as soon as we removed the
d-forming force this restoring force
comes into play and restores the body to
its original shape plastic deformations
on the other hand are the deformations
that permanently change the shape of the
body the applied force here is simply
too much for the body to bed and that
results in permanent deformation now
which objects show elastic deformation
and which ones show plastic deformations
generally all the objects show both type
of deformations yes for instance a
features keep extending the spring
forever there will be a certain limit
beyond which the length would increase
further and if we try to apply more
force the spring may loosen and end up
breaking so the spring shows elastic
deformation up to some extent beyond
which it results in plastic deformation
spring is like a common example
generally almost every object shows both
elastic as well as plastic nature the
elastic limits depends on the d-forming
force applied on the object and the
properties of the material they're made
up of and it is important for engineers
to note the elastic limits of things
such as metal beams
and concrete that is the limit to which
they can uphold the Lord without getting
permanently deformed or cracked now we
come to an extremely important topic the
Hookes law Robert Hooke an English
physicist stated that the empirical law
in 1660 which is today known by the name
Hookes law
what does empirical mean it means the
law was derived using observations it
states for elastic deformation in a
string the deforming force is directly
proportional to change in length
consider a spring of length L whose one
end is fixed from the end suppose the
stretching force F is applied on the
other end now let the change in its
length be Delta L the law states that
the force F is directly proportional to
Delta L now what do we mean in
mathematics when one quantity is
directly proportional to the other it
means that one thing is some constant
times the other so we can write force F
is K times Delta L where K is the
proportionality constant this is the
mathematical form of Hookes law in some
textbooks you must have noticed the
presence of negative sign on the right
side of this equation the negative sign
comes due to the slightly different
version of the Hookes law being followed
we can also define Hookes law as the
restoring force is directly proportional
to change in length and this of course
is valid for elastic deformation only
the force taken here is the restoring
force and not d-forming force the
negative sign only tells us that the
restoring force is opposite to the
direction in which the length is
changing another thing is that this law
is not only valid for elastic
deformation in a spring it's also valid
for elastic deformation in any material
but there is an assumption that this law
is valid when the forces and D
formations are relatively small also
there is a modified version of Hookes
law it says that in an elastic
deformation the stress experienced by a
body is directly proportional to strain
before understanding this modified
version we need to understand what
stress and strain mean and we will do
that in the next video
[Music]